mais mes chers amis lorsque j'avais
décidé de me présenter à l'élection pour
la présidence de notre famille politique
je m'étais engagé à la transformer en
profondeur
après les divisions qui nous ont tant
coûté collectivement et que personne n'a
oublié je me souviens de l'état dans
lequel j'ai trouvé ma famille politique
cela faisait 11 à tant de militants à
travers la foi patiemment
patiemment nous avons jeté les bases
tous ensemble de ce qui est devenu la
première formation politique de france
et nous avons tous ensemble donner tort
à ceux qui prédisaient la dislocation de
notre mouvement
dix-huit mois après nous sommes ensemble
beaucoup plus fort que nous l'étions
le mérite en revient à chacun d'entre
vous nous nous sommes rassemblés sur
l'essentiel
nous avons fait l'effort d'apaiser les
tensions internes
rappelez vous on ne faisait pas
d'élections puisqu'on se faisait si peu
confiance qu'on s'accuser les uns contre
les autres
rappelez vous on ne faisait pas de
réunion du conseil national puisque
c'était pas l'expression de différence
mais que ça donnait le sentiment deux
clans qui s'opposaient les uns aux
autres et malgré un contexte disons le
cheikh issa laye sensible et bien jamais
jamais notre unité collective ne s'est
fissurée nous avons créé une nouvelle
formation politique dont le nom et les
statuts ont été approuvés par nos
adhérents
je me souviens encore y compris mes
propres amis
nicolas
tient compte du conservatisme ambiant ne
change pas le nom
ils sont habitués et puis qui a promis
de faire une formation démocratique ne
lui fait pas voter tu risques d'être
battus et dewet innombrables étaient
ceux qui étaient contre
à l'arrivée tous sont maintenant pour
qui est en désaccord avec cette idée que
la république ne peut pas reculer parce
que nous sommes les républicains et que
nous n'accepterons pas ces reculs
la survie financière de la première
force d'opposition cher daniel fasquelle
était en jeu nous avons remboursé une
partie importante des dettes du parti et
nous avons été deux surcroît capable
d'auto financer le coût des primaires
sans un centime d'emprunt en plus et je
ne vais pas m'excuser parce que depuis
18 mois
je n'ai pas levé d'argent pour ma
prétendue candidature mais pour la
famille politique est la nôtre et
qu'elle avait besoin
et à ma connaissance cher thierry il ya
peu des candidats déclarés qui ont
apporté leur obole pour le financement
de la campagne des primaires ce sont les
républicains collectivement qui
financeront la prochaine campagne des
primaires 5 millions nous avons
renouvelé par la démocratie interne
l'ensemble des instances locales et
nationales
ces multiples élections non à ma
connaissance donné lieu à quasiment
aucune contestation
nous avons dynamiser notre force
militante
chaque jour notre famille s'agrandit et
je suis heureux de vous annoncer puisque
les fichiers devaient être arrêtés au 30
juin que nous transmettrons à la haute
autorité
un fichier de 260 5000 adhérents à jour
de cotisation ce qui fait de nous est de
loin la première
formation politique du pays nous avons
remporté les élections départementales
se souvient tous ces observateurs très
compétent tous ces spécialistes de la
politique dont le point commun est de ne
jamais s'être présenté une élection et
qui disait c'est pas moins d'une dizaine
de départements qui passeront sur la
férule du front national à l'arrivée il
n'y en a eu zéro parce qu'on était unie
et parce que tous ensemble nous avons
fait campagne
on a gagné les régionales je veux rendre
hommage à nos candidats parce que ce fut
une campagne épouvantablement difficile
dans un climat françois d'une violence
inouïe puisqu'il y avait eu les barbares
qui avait ravagé ces personnes qui
avaient été au bataclan et les terrasses
de paris
les élections étaient quinze jours après
et malgré tout il a fallu prendre la
décision de continuer à faire des
élections parce que sur le territoire
la république c'est pas une bande de
barbares qui va nous empêcher de
défendre nos idées et d'aller à la
rencontre des français
l'élection de xavier bertrand dans le
nord pas de calais picardie
à l'époque ce fut une joie pour tout
notre famille politique parce que nous
voulions pas de marie lebel christian
estrosi dans le sud parce que nous ne
voulons pas la fille honor
et la nièce au sud j'ai dit à philippe
ce que j'en pensais mais j'aurais quand
même dire à notre vice-président que
ronald ou verne
heureusement tu étais pas lé meilleur
candidat parce que qu'est-ce que
s'arrêtaient devant nous mais là et je
pourrais rajouter de leurs hôtes ayo et
bien sûr valérie pécresse qui nous a
apporté un succès remarquable en ile de
france
à l'arrivée à l'arrêt
selon les pronostics qui nous réservait
le sort de l'autriche
on a gagné la quasi-totalité des
élections partielles législatives et
dans le même temps j'ai dit un mot de
l'autriche qui peut dire que si nous
n'avions pas fait tous ceux ci nous ne
serions pas retrouver dans la situation
des formations de gouvernements de
droite comme de gauche en août riches
qui ont fini à 11 % laissant un deuxième
coup grotesque entre le leader d'extrême
droite il ya un écologiste bobos que
personne ne connaissait en autriche et
ce qui a voté une élection qui de
surcroît est annulé voilà ce que nous
avons évité
alors aujourd'hui nous avons un projet
et moi je veux rendre hommage à eric
woerth
j'avais apprécié son courage
sa probité
c'est bien toi françois quand il était
au gouvernement à nos côtés et qu'il a
été lâchement insulté justice eut été
rendue c'est un honneur d'abord eric
woerth comme secrétaire général
ayant la sagesse de ne pas condamner
trop d'eau eric woerth qui a beaucoup
souffert mais moi je suis fier d'être
ton ami et je suis fier que tu aies
accepté général
je veux y associer isabelle le callennec
lorsqu'isabelle fait partie de ces
jeunes et nouveaux talents
dans notre famille a besoin vous avez
évoqué l'immense majorité est pour le
projet certains et c'est parfaitement
leurs droits sont contre mais mes chers
amis réfléchissant qu'est ce que ray
qu'est ce que serait une formation
politique sans un projet une machine à
donner des investitures un club de
supporters une association de femmes
j'ai voulu un parti politique et quand
on m'a dit mais les primaires feront la
faire non ya un parti politique il doit
avoir un projet un projet collectif qui
engage la famille politique de l'année
la synthèse c'est pas facile bien sûr
mais ce coup qu'est ce qu'on veut vous
gagnez on veut rassembler
on veut être cohérent alors il faut
accepter d'avancer ensemble et non pas
séparément chacun de son côté
notre famille est aujourd'hui en ordre
de marche
mais je voudrais dire un mot aux
adhérents que vous représentez vous êtes
là parce que vous aimez la france parce
que vous tous qui êtes ici vous l'êtes
pas ce qu'on appelle des professionnels
vous pourriez nos familles vous pourriez
être à vous occuper de votre travail
vous pourriez tout simplement vous
reposer mais vous soyez avait choisi
d'être là parce que vous aimez la france
est bien comme on aime la france comme
vous l'aimez
ça mérite le respect et je demande le
respect pour les adhérents de notre
famille politique c'est grâce à vous qu
on a tenu
c'est grâce à vous qu'on est là c'est
grâce à vous que demain on peut gagner
vous respectez vous considérez
sony reconduit de ce que vous dites est
ce que vous proposez c'est facile d'être
sur le trottoir et parler à quelques
journalistes c'est moins facile d'être
au milieu des siens dans la famille
politique qu'elle anneaux pour porter
ses idées
et oui me laurent je respecte le choix
de françois fillon d'être là de nadine
morano d'être là de miss aisne et nos
maris d'être la der des maris temps
d'être là parce que c'est à l'intérieur
quand on a des choses à dire qu'on les
dit pas l'extérieur
chacun avait la possibilité de prendre
la parole chacun
y'a pas de biais
viens juste des femmes et des hommes qui
aiment leur pays et puis doivent être
capables d'entraîner derrière eux
il manque
au khalife de la france
non
les années oui mais sabine je veux
simplement dire deux choses
comment prétendre à la direction de la
france le redressement de la france
si nous n'avions pas cher philippe était
capable de redresser notre propre
famille politique
il aurait été beau l'exemple il aurait
été rassurant notre avantage on laisse
notre formation politique se détruire se
déliter s'effondrer mais audi ou
français
rassurez-vous ce qu'on n'est même pas
capable de faire pour notre famille on
sera capable de faire pour notre pays
non on à redresser notre famille parce
qu'on va redresser la preuve voilà dans
cet ordre là et qu'on ferait puylaurens
de la dénonciation je crois pouvoir dire
sir edouard balladur que tous nous
l'avons dénoncée stigmatiser françois
hollande parce qu'ils divisent les
français et pas capable de rassembler
notre famille pas être capable de
s'écouter pas être capable de dialoguer
pas être capable de supporter quelqu'un
qui a un avis différent sur tel ou tel
sujet mais c'est notre devoir de
rassembler des différences et d'en faire
une cohérence
alors aujourd'hui nous voyons quoi nous
voyons les conséquences désastreuses du
mensonge de 2012 la loi le comme riz
n'est pour rien les français ont compris
depuis longtemps car rien qu'au pire ça
changerait rien
ce qui est intéressant c'est le mensonge
c'est le sentiment d'impuissance
c'est la perte d'autorité c'est le
désordre qui risquent de détourner
chaque jour davantage les français de la
politique car le problème en contrôlant
ses qui peut pas se faire davantage de
mal à lui même au niveau il en est ça
peut guère aller beaucoup beaucoup plus
bas mais peut tous nous entraîner il
peut tous nous entraîner dans cette
faillite qui est la sienne la frange des
creux la france décroche
notre économie ne redémarre pas et quand
françois fillon fixe un objectif de 2
constants il est crédible parce que je
vous rappelle que la dernière année de
mon quinquennat
le taux de croissance a été de 2,1 pour
cent quand nous leur promettons c'est
que nous avons été capables de faire la
pression fiscale écrase les menace
la menace terroriste et la crise
migratoire laisse planer des dangers
permanents les désordres du monde
on a très bien parlé pierre lellouche
la dislocation du continent européen je
reviens de londres le bric site est déjà
derrière eux puisque ceux qui les
occupent maintenant c lip l'explosion
l'implosion du royaume uni et c'est pas
fini
notre pays qui s'enfonce dans une forme
de chaos
un jour c'est la place de la république
qui est occupé avec des ateliers qui
sont interdits au blanc pour ne pas que
des minorités se sentent persécutés
un autre c'est donc un hôpital pour
enfants qui est attaqué par des pseudos
syndicaliste et un troisième ce sont des
indices qui provoque en toute impunité
la république en occupant illégalement
des dizaines d'hectares
il est grand temps que tout ceci se
termine parce que ça se termine déjà
très mal la république et provoquer la
république et offensé la république et
humilié nous ne pouvons plus accepter ce
spectacle alors je ne reviendrai pas sur
le projet qui était formidablement
présenté par eric mais qui me soit
permis d'évoquer trois sujets politiques
d'abord ce projet il est le projet de
notre famille politique
bien sûr les candidats à la primaire
pour un les plus ou moins loin cela va
de soi qu'est ce qui a d'ailleurs jamais
empêché une femme ou un homme politique
de dire ce qu'il pense d'aller plus ou
moins loin bien sûr ce projet on peut
considérer qu'il y a dans les quelques
trois cent soixante quinze pages des
mesures qui vous plaisent beaucoup
d'autres qui vous plaisent - et
peut-être même tel ou tel avec lequel on
est en désaccord mais ce projet est un
socle 1 ce qui témoigne que ce qui nous
rassemble est plus fort que ce qui nous
divise
avoir un socle commun n'a jamais
signifié qu'on va effacer les nuances
qu'on va refuser les différences est
d'accord sur un soc
ça n'enlève nullement l'originalité de
chacun mais à l'inversé dire le
contraire refuser d'avoir un socle
cela signifierait donc que nous n'avons
rien en commun qui pourrait l'accepter
et surtout qui pourrait le comprendre
quand on n'étaye à peine quelques années
ensemble au gouvernement il y en a assez
peu qu'ils m'ont dit je t'en supplie je
veux sortir du gouvernement tellement
chiant d accord avec toi
ce qui était vrai hier ça doit l'être
aujourd'hui et demain qu'en france
mallinder nos lots remportés la porte à
parier qu'ils n'ont bras bleus seront
les candidats pour se rassembler
derrière ce projet qui les représente si
bien tant enthousiasme dans un moment
détente suspicion dans une eau et bien
moi j'ai fait un rêve c'est de demain
plutôt que d'insister continuellement
sur nos différences est ce que ça ne
serait pas bien que nous décidions
désormais de mettre en avant nos
innombrables convergence c'est ce
qu'attendent les français
la deuxième remarque que je veux faire
politique c'est que tous les français
doivent pouvoir se reconnaître dans ce
projet je les dis ce matin parlant à
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
considération qui est serge dassault
mais ce n'est pas une plaisanterie ce
projet c'est un projet pour une
catégorie de français
ce projet c'est pas le projet de l'un
contre l'autre
ce n'est même pas le projet de l'un sans
l'autre
c'est le projet de toute la france la
france dans toutes ses composantes
c'est le projet de millions de français
qui habitent en zone rurale et qui ont
droit à ce qu'un plan marshall met fin
au sentiment d'abandon qu'éprouve la
ruralité qui ne veut pas être rayé de la
carte
nous devons porter un discours de
défense de la ruralité cher la ville
parce que la réalité c'est une partie de
l'identité française est bien au delà de
nos différences
herbert ce combat pour que la ruralité
ne disparaissent pas peut-être le combat
de chacun d'entre nous
le projet des agriculteurs je pense une
chose vraiment sexy nous ne baissons pas
massivement les charges que supportent
nos agriculteurs dans dix ans il n'y
aura plus de production agricole cher
christian jacob sur le territoire de
notre pays que ce soit alain gebel
françois fillon
nous le maire qui vous voulez la
problème de la disparition de notre
agriculture est posée à tous et ne
pouvons plus accepter cette concurrence
déloyale
nous demandons que si taxe carbone il ya
ce soit une taxe carbone aux frontières
de l'europe pour que les pays qui ne
respectent aucune des règles qu'on veut
faire respecter à nos industriels soient
taxés avant que leur produit soit
acceptée sur les marchés européens
le projet de tous les chefs de petites
entreprises les artisans les commerçants
qui se bat contre l'excellent oui je le
suis j'ai proposé que nous mettions fin
au principe de précaution qui avec le
temps est devenu un principe
d'interdiction et que nous le remplaçons
par un principe de responsabilité pour
comme luc chatel l'a dit nous
réconcilions la france avec le progrès
avec l'innovation avec la science on va
pas retourner à l'époque de la bougie il
ya quelque chose d'effrayant de voir
qu'on exige la fermeture de fessenheim
parce que quelques écologistes transfert
de l'extrême gauche voudrait que la
france refuse par principe tout progrès
bien sûr que c'est le projet qui est le
nôtre
sept projets des acteurs du numérique
que j'ai rencontrés avec eric woerth
encore avant-hier à londres et qui
partent à l'on dit non expliqué pourquoi
parce qu'à londres on peut lever des
capitaux qu'on ne trouve pas à paris
parce que nous sommes le pays le plus
bancarisés d'europe et que des
entrepreneurs les plus efficaces ne
peuvent pas trouver les investissements
qu'il trouve à 30 km de les côtes
françaises parce qu'ils sont à londres
alors au moins profitant de
l'opportunité de la sortie des anglais
pour faire de paris la première fois les
places financières et la première place
d'investissement du monde
c'est le projet de tous ceux me
semble-t-il qui quelle que soit leur
origine chez rachida veulent que la
france renoue avec l'autorité avec la
laïcité
avec ces valeurs qui font la république
c'est projette millions de français qui
sont frappés par le chômage et qui
seront les premiers bénéficiaires de
l'exonération totale des charges au
niveau du smig que nous proposons on va
pas continuer à être les champions
d'europe du chômage 6 millions de
chômeurs c'est une bombe qui va nous
exploser dessus c'est une bombe d'art
fragmentation faut bien faire quelque
chose et donc on n'attendra pas que les
économies produisent leurs résultats
pour faire une baisse massive de chasse
au niveau du smig pour qu à toute force
qui sont aujourd'hui un extérieur de
l'emploi puisse trouver à l'emploi c'est
un projet pour le monde de la culture
non monsieur hollande le monde de la
culture français n'attend pas qu'on les
flatte
ils attendent un gouvernement qui porte
la culture française qu'ils défendent la
création française et qu'il valorise la
langue française plutôt que de donner le
sentiment de l'abandonner
ce projet là doit parler à tout le monde
je suis tout à fait d'accord hervé on
doit mettre les chefs d'entreprise et
les entreprises au coeur de notre projet
mais les salariés doivent pas se sentir
exclu mais les ouvriers que nous avions
récupéré
parce que nous avions eu le courage de
faire les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées contre toute
l'administration de bercy qui n'en
voulait pas eux ils attendent aussi de
nous
on va parler laissé tomber ils ont aussi
le droit d'avoir une formation politique
qui parle pour eux la gauche a abandonné
le peuple parce que la gauche n'aime
plus le peuple parce que la gauche pense
que le peuple est sécuritaire donc la
gauche s'est trouvé une minorité
opprimée justement par le
communautarisme et bien nous nous devons
parler à tous les français et c'est ça
la magie du projet qui est le nôtre
alors au fond notre prochain ces projets
du peuple de france parce que le mérite
c'est une valeur du peuple de france
parce que le travail c'est une valeur du
peuple de france parce que les forces et
une valeur du peuple de france parce que
l'autorité c'est une valeur du peuple de
france
alors j'entends ceux qui me disent oui
la rente un peu de mépris
moi je pense que le bon héritage est un
des plus beaux mots de la langue
française
parce que ça prouve combien de quelque
part qu'on a des racines qu'avant soient
ses parents et ses grands-parents ont
travaillé dur et on va quand même pas
s'excuser qui vous ai laissé quelque
chose
la propriété c'est pas du vol et qu'on
gagne plus quand on prend plus de
risques d autres c'est normal et c'est
aussi parce que j'ai voulu que nous
parlions français les plus modestes que
nous avons refusé d'inscrire dans notre
projet l'augmentation de la tva parce
que j'estime qu'après quatre années de
frénésie fiscale
nous devons entendre la colère fiscal
des français et que nous les
républicains nous ne pouvons pas dire
nous dénonçons les 50 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts de monsieur
hollande
mais à notre tour lorsque nous
arriverons ou le baisser les impôts ou
les augmentera mes chers amis ce projet
est en rupture avec l'idéologie
socialiste et avec la pensée unique
tout à l'heure ce matin avec jean
françois copé et j'aime bien moins quand
on n'échange quand on discute
quand ton argument en tout cas quand je
suis là
il ya un débat entre nous et c'est un
débat médiocre il ya ceux dont je suis
qui pensent qu'une alternance sans
baisse des impôts ne serait pas
d'alternance il y en a d'autres
c'est leur droit qui pense qu'il faut
attendre que les baisses de dépenses
produisent des recettes pour qu'après
une baisse des impôts et bien sûr on
attend cela
on sera morts avant que d'être guéries
ou plutôt on sera mort kerry la
réduction des dépenses tout de suite et
la baisse des impôts tout de suite la
pensée unique
ce projet est en rupture avec la pensée
unique c'est celle qui s'accrochent à
des mots qui ne veut plus rien dire le
mot intégration ne signifie plus rien
tant il a été rebattues quand on a
recensé les oreilles de chacun avec
l'intégration cissé nous l'alternance
nous ne voulons pas de l'intégration
nous voulons de la simulation
celui qui arrive s'il veut devenir
français qui parlent français
ils adoptent le mode de vie français il
est fier d'être français et à l'école on
n'apprend pas l'histoire de ses parents
du pays d'origine de ses parents
mais l'histoire du pays qui viennent
d'adopter l'histoire de france et pas
une autre
c'est un comble
je vois que maintenant
je me souviens la première fois que
j'avais utilisé l'expression les racines
chrétiennes c'était chez jean pierre
raffarin n'était je crois pas loin de
poitiers à l'époque ça avait fait un
grand scandale
je vois que maintenant ça fait un grand
consensus
eh bien je m'en réjouis mais les racines
chrétiennes qui sont les nôtres c'est
parce que nous sommes des humanistes et
c'est ce qui fait la grande différence
entre nous et le front national
moi je suis pour le contrôle de
l'immigration et j'ai dit la semaine
dernière madame merkel qu'on peut plus
continuer à accepter tous ceux qui
fuient à cause de la famine de la guerre
de la désespérance l'afrique parce qu'on
va faire exploser notre pacte social
mais je n'accepte pas la façon de madame
le pen parle de ces gens parce que ce
sont des êtres humains
et quelle que soit la couleur de leur
peau quelle que soit leur histoire ce
sont en matière d'humanités des frères
par rapport à nous on peut pas être
humaniste et le traiter comme des
statistiques ferme et humains ferme
parce que nous sommes responsables
humain parce que nous sommes les
héritiers d'une pensée chrétienne la
pensée unique la pensée unique sur
l'europe
oh là là qu est ce qu on entre on est
servi dans notre famille a toujours eu
des souverainistes toujours film est
bien pour moi les souverainistes
c'est des amis avec qui je peux
parfaitement m'entendre il ya même eu
dans les gouvernements que nous avons
constitué des gens qui était
souverainiste et je les place pas nés au
dessus et en dessous intellectuellement
d euros lattre je comprends parfaitement
qu'on aime l'europe moi même mon idéal
pairs européens est inscrit dans mes
gènes mais faire la synthèse entre les
deux
cela veut dire que on peut pas
considérer que 74 % de britanniques qui
prennent la parole que 17 millions de
britanniques qui disent non c'est une
anecdote on peut quand même pas
considéré qu'en 2005 on l'a déjà oublié
les français se prononcent contre
l'europe
à combien de pau 155% et je crois que
c'est nadine ce matin qui a dit si le
référendum avait eu lieu dans un autre
pays qui pourrait dire qu'ils auraient
pas eu le même résultat
y compris mes chers amis en allemagne où
l'inquiétude est beaucoup plus
importante qu'on le dit nous devons
quand même tenir compte de cela on peut
pas s'en tenir simplement à cette idée
que l'europe c'est notre projet et tous
ceux qui ne comprennent pas ne
comprennent rien j'ai dit ce matin le
problème c'est pas le référendum
ah oui c'est un problème le référendum
parce que la réponse du pape ne
correspond pas à ce qu'on aurait
souhaité nous sommes les républicains
donc il faut bien faire la synthèse de
cette inquiétude et profiter de cette
crise pour redresser l'europe et pour la
refonder la dernière réunion de notre
bureau politique à l'unanimité nous
avons voté un texte qui nous a rassemblé
de toi philippe richert et la tradition
qui était la tienne
au plus souverainiste d'entre nous où
est le mal à faire ça est ce qu'on peut
se rassembler sans s'affadir est ce que
le compromis c'est forcément un
affadissement je ne pense pas je pense
qu'on peut garder la cohérence
on entend dans les discours des deux
côtés et quand on est fort on peut te
dire le rassemblement d'une famille
complexe à diriger elle est complexe
parce qu elle est grande elle est
complexe parce qu'elle est large mais
sur les pas capable de diriger cette
famille politique
alors comment seront capables de diriger
la france et ses 70 millions d'habitants
enfin
j'entends j'entends ce qu'on me dit sûre
il faudra le faire à l'époque quand
j'étais président que françois des
premiers ministres les doter des
ministres ce qui était au parlement
expliqué que c'était la coproduction
législative donc à l'époque on était en
coproduction maintenant je suis le seul
producteur si j'ai bien compris
à l'époque ce qu'on faisait on le
faisait ensemble et maintenant j'ai dû
être tout seul vous savez mes chers à
bille en cinq ans et ça n'a pas été
facile on n'a jamais reculé jamais
reculer devant la rue et on a pu le
faire sans violence
pourquoi parce qu'on a laissé aller le
débat et je pense que quand on est fort
on n'utilise pas le 49-3 je sais
parfaitement que le 49-3 fait partie de
la 5e à doubler mais c'était une autre
époque
l'époque a changé on n'est plus à
l'époque de madame thatcher
on n'est plus à l'époque de monsieur
reagan on est même but en 1958
on est à l'époque du numérique des
réseaux de l'actualité récente
on était à l'époque de la pression
continue moi je crois que dans cette
époque des méthodes artificiel pour
bloquer pour empêcher le débat cd preuve
de faiblesse
lorsque nous avons fait la réforme des
retraites souviens toi nombreux étaient
les pressions qu'ils me demandaient de
mettre le 49-3 j'ai dit non on va
laisser la majorité débattre et la
majorité va débattre avec l'opposition
et on a débattu souvient temps eric sa
durée des jours et des jours des nuits
et des nuits
oui mais à l'arrivée le débat qui a lieu
au parlement c'est de la violence que
vous n'avez pas dans la rue monsieur
hollande a eu tort surtout il aurait dû
laisser le parlement débat
il aurait dû interdire la violence dans
la rue
le contraire que nous avons fait alors
voilà
pour terminer je voudrais vous dire un
mot de l'avenir proche
parce que les mois qui viennent vont
être d'une grande importance pour notre
famille politique est encore plus pour
la france à partir du mois de septembre
sur thierry les primaires vont commencer
il faut que je m'explique sur le
pourquoi j'ai voulu demeurer à la tête
de notre mouvement
j'ai voulu rester à la tête de notre
mouvement jusqu'à ce que les primaires
comment ce corps et on dit mes chers
amis
qu'aurait-on dit si on plaint briques
side dans une situation de crise majeure
pour l'europe il n'y avait eu à la tête
de notre famille politique
une direction provisoire quelles que
soient ses qualités pas une direction
élue une direction provisoire ou même
pas de direction
qu'aurait-on dit si il ya quelques
semaines devant le spectacle un sens et
des violences qui ont enflammé les rues
de nos différentes villes les
républicains étaient inaudibles
alors qu'il fallait fixer une ligne et
incarner une alternative corps et ont
pensé da président des républicains élus
démocratiquement pour cinq ans qui
quitte la présidence sans se préoccuper
du projet de sa famille politique sans
se préoccuper des investitures pour les
législatives qui auront lieu dans un
peine un an au seul prétexte qu'il se
dépêchait d'être candidat aux primaires
qui ne manquait pas par ailleurs de
candidats
quand récompensés comme en corée qu'on
dit on aurait dit que je laissais
monsieur hollande sans un chef de
l'opposition crédible pour lui apporter
la contradiction et qui aurait invité
monsieur hollande pour discuter avec lui
des conséquences du bric side ou de ce
qu'il fallait faire quand le pari était
sous l'emprise des terroristes ils
auraient choisi lui même celles et ceux
d'entre nous qui devait représenter la
famille avec le vice et la perversité et
les siennes un jour ils invitent l1 un
jour hélas vite et l'autre pour jouer
avec nous comme un chat joue avec une
souris je les ai pas voulu parce que
vous m'avez porté à la présidence du
mouvement
quelle autre et j'ai bien l'intention de
terminer le travail qui est le mien
voilà ce que je pense de la
responsabilité
responsable
jazz ou j'ajoute
photo ja jours j'ajoute que je vois
beaucoup davantage au fond est ce qu'on
appelle à quitter ses responsabilités ça
veut donc dire que le siège est plus
rembourrés je ne le pensais parce qu'il
fut un temps où bien peu de gens
voulaient s'asseoir à cette place et
assumer les responsabilités qui était la
mienne
après tout tant mieux ça prouve que les
républicains sont de plus fort et ça
pouvait être président des républicains
ce un avantage et bien je vous en
remercie parce que c'est vous qui avez
fait que la présidence des républicains
soit un avantage parce que jusqu'à
présent
ç'avait été un désavantage ça prouve
qu'on est passé de la faiblesse à la
force
et finalement c'est la meilleure
nouvelle pour notre famille politique
alors alors
cette primaire
cette primaire ça sera le temps de la
concurrence
et de la concurrence entre deux fortes
personnalités entre des talents
incontestables
cette concurrence meilleur ami personne
ne doit la redoute et personne parce
qu'elle est la force de notre famille
moi j'aime l'idée d'une famille
politique où il ya des talents qui ont
le courage de se mettre en danger en
concurrence pour assumer le leadership
d'une famille politique
cette famille est vivant cette famille
une talentueuse cette famille regarde le
talent tant mieux on va pas s'en excuser
je vais vous dire une chose vous le
prendre et j'espère très bien il suffit
pas d'avoir moins de talent pour avoir
moins de concurrence j'en connais
tellement des formations politiques où
il ya de la concurrence et pas de talent
alors dans cette primaire chacun devra
donner le meilleur de lui même
les français choisiront leur choix sera
le bon jeu mais juste une limite cette
concurrence et je vous parlais très
sérieusement de cette limite
la limite c'est l'unité de notre famille
politique donner le meilleur de soi même
donné le maximum je sais faire et je
suis sûr que d'autres seront faire mais
quand la droite va au combat
elle doit se battre sur deux fronts le
front de la gauche et elles font
l'extrême droite
c'est pour ça qu'il est inacceptable que
nous nous attaquions entre nous il y a
suffisamment à dire à gogo et au front
national pour qu'on accepte pas les
attaques entre nous elles sont
inacceptables inacceptables
j'ai mon conseil
c'est que vous fassiez de l'attitude de
chacun
un critère de choix on n'a pas besoin de
faire de la publicité pour soi même en
attaquant les membres de sa famille
on peut faire de la publicité pour
soi-même en développement l'originalité
de son projet l'originalité que sa
personne pas en attaquant les autres
parce que ça va durer beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'on le croit
trois mois c'est une éternité dans la
vie politique qui est la nôtre
enfin il y avait tous ceux qui
s'interrogeaient sur le sens que pouvait
bien avoir pour moi y compris mes amis
d'avoir été président de la république
puis d'être devenu président de notre
famille et bien moi je veux vous dire
que j'ai profondément aimé diriger notre
mouvement et vous savez
un certain nombre de ceux qui sont ici
au premier rang des spas edwards vous
étiez à mes côtés en 2007 aussi françois
quand j'ai été élu président de la
république je peux en parler parce qu'à
ma connaissance sur le site seul parmi
nous tu eu cet honneur
j'ai été bouleversée moins que les
français choisissent ça restera
l'honneur de ma vie j'avais dit à la
mutualité
après la défaite de 2012 que jamais
j'aurais assez dedans pour remercier les
français de cet honneur ceux qui avaient
voté pour moi mais ceux qui n'avaient
pas voté pour moi mais qui m'appellent
et c'est en quelque sorte gouverner sans
violence et sans drame mais je suis
quelqu'un de particulier voyez vous
c'était un grand honneur mais quand vous
m'avez choisie pour être président de la
famille je n'ai pas cet honneur sur le
même plan et ça m'a touché qui est tant
de gens qui fassent confiance qui est en
chantier les sentiments j'ai tant d'amis
malgré ce que disait la presse malgré
les polémiques
malgré les attaques incessantes qui
fasse confiance que le lien qu est la
chose la plus précieuse au monde
le lien qui peut se détendre qui pousse
trop tendres que ce lien là et résister
à tout ça m'a bouleversé
j'étais fier d'être président de la
république mais président des
républicains dans la période qu'on a
connu croyez moi c'est aussi une fierté
pour moi
alors quoi qu'il arrive dans les
semaines qui viennent ce conseil
national
eh bien ça sera mon dernier en tant que
président des républicains
le dernier
et c'est donc la dernière fois que je
peux vous dire merci geo dire une chose
n'oubliez ni l'impératif de l'unité ni
l'impératif de la france et moi dans
cette salle ici je peux regarder tous
ceux qui sont là j'ai tant de souvenirs
avec vous vous êtes tous mes amis et
jamais je n'oublierai ce lien de
l'amitié entre vous et moi jamais vive
la république vive la france et vive la
république